- L'avenir sera chaud, très
chaud, a
La chaleur deviendra si intense
dans certaines régions que
les humains ne pourraient plustn
avec la Croix-Rouge, a recensé
dans un rapport les vagues
de chaleur. Elle conclut
de certaines des catastrophes
les plus meurtrières jamais
enregistrées.
"C'est peut-être quelque chose
chef
de l'agence humanitaire.
Rappelons qu'en Europe en 2003
près de 70 000 personnes
sont mortes en raison c'est 55 .
Et cette année encore
des régions ont suffoqué.
a fondu  33 jours de
canicule consécutifs en France.s
uest de la Chine.
nt
les plus vulnérables.
En 2021, la Canada
Lytton en Colombie-Britannique.
Le pays est mal préparé à
l'augmentation des températures
JOANNA EYQUEM, DG, Centre intaco
- On dit que c'est le tueur
silencieux, parce qu'on ne
se rend pas compte
parce qu'on voit pas les gens
qui sontpar les îlots
de chaleur.
- D'ici 2080, des vagues de
chaleur s'abattrons'abattrons'ad
du pays, principalement le long
de la frontière américaine
et la vallée du Saint-Laurent,T.
mandes
de réfugiés climatique.
- Les gens, ils commencent
à être inquiets de la migration
vers le Canada, mais on ne voite
encore pire.
- À moins d'un mois de la
l'ONU et la Croix-Rouge
souhaitent une prise
de conscience, mais aussi
Ici Mar Ici Mar Ici Mar Ici Mau
Radio-Canada, Mon